[Applaudissements]
nous sommes présents
sur ce petit caillou qu'est la réunion
mémoire je viens d'un plus petit caillou
encore un caillou six fois plus petit
que la réunion située dans l'océan
indien s'est il s'appelle en juin en
janvier c'est et mer turquoise un
paysage magnifique une population
accueillante
à cette époque mon père et ma mère et
travailler ma mère travaillait pour un
magasin familial et mon père lui pour le
gouvernement comorien
moi aussi je suis né sur ce même petit
caillou ce petit bijou appelé en juin
après mon bac je pars en france dans la
ville de toulouse où mes études
supérieures à la fin des études
j'obtiens une job d'été dans une banque
un os tissu du call on me propose un
contrat de stagiaire pour intégrer
définitivement la banque mais quelques
temps avant la fin de ce stage je reçois
un appel de mon père des comores qui me
demandent instamment de rentrée pour
être à ses côtés
très attaché à mes parents et sachant
que c'est con vieux je décide donc de
rentrer jeudi à lormont à mon chef et
j'accepte et l'emploi du gouvernement
comorien et que je quitte la bande
ce dernier a déçu et surpris me dis mais
qu'est ce que vous allez faire dans ce
petit pays en 1988
je quitte moi même ce petit pays avec
les parents et on part pour paris
mon père est affecté à l'ambassade des
comores en tant que conseiller justement
alors je me souviens de cette ambassade
j'étais gamin elle était magnifique mais
je me souvenais surtout le fait super
beau look est tout rouge a été éclatante
et qui ornaient les couloirs un peu
comme ce tapis les souvenirs
j'ai de mon père en tant que diplomate
ce sont les voyages qui l'effectué mais
surtout j'étais petit c'était surtout
ils voyagent pas surtout bardot les
cadeaux qu'ils me ramener lors de ses
voyages comme par exemple il était
revenu un joueur de new york
il m'avait ramené la game boy ceux
d'entre vous qui connaissez cette
console au kilo connu ne comprennent
sûrement et puis il y avait aussi cette
voiture avec sa plaque verte et orange
savez symbole des plaques diplomatiques
donc quelques souvenirs par ci par là et
fin 1989 il se passe un événement
tragique aux comores fête en cette fin
1989 le tristement célèbre mercenaire
bob denard qui avait déjà eu à son actif
deux coup d'état aux comores assassine
le président les cobras le gouvernement
comorien organise donc de nouvelles
élections
un nouveau président est élu suite à ces
les nouvelles autorités décident de
renvoyer une partie du personnel
diplomatique en poste à paris dont - je
me retrouve donc du jour au lendemain au
chômage désemparés face à cette
situation aussi brutale qu'inattendue
et il va se passer trois années avant
que je retrouve un nouvel emploi un jour
j'avais à peu près 9 10 ans je suis en
bas de l'immeuble et ont invité je suis
en train de m'amuser avec les amis et là
je vois débarquer le facteur avec son
scooter et son manteau jaune et bleu et
quand il s'approche je m'aperçois que
c'est mon père
je comprends rien mon père il n'est pas
facteur il est diplomate
il est toujours en voiture il est pense
coutteure je vous faire une confidence
devant mes amis j'étais gêné j'en avais
même un peu honte et en fait je me suis
dit que si moi je ressentais ça mais
qu'est-ce que ça devait être pour lui ça
devait être pierre mais ce jour là il ya
quelque chose qui m'a davantage marqué
c'était font sourire et le sourire de ce
facteur
il est resté avec moi et m'a influencé
pendant toute ma vie le sourire de ce
facteur est en fait celui de cet homme
mon père en fait c'était tel un policier
ça devenait après trois années de
recherche permanente d'emploi ont tué
d'allers et retours incessants et très
souvent et fructueux entre les bureaux
parfois je vous demandais est ce qu'un
jour je vais voir le bout le verra pas
voir le bout du tunnel et la lumière est
apparue enfin lorsque j'ai pu décrocher
mon premier emploi celui de facteurs au
il est facile d'imaginer que je ne
m'entendais pas du tout deux à être omis
facteurs
cependant il y avait des avantages à
être facteur par exemple lorsque les
jambes invité chez eux à prendre le thé
ou le café pendant une petite pause dans
la distribution du courrier
c'est un avantage et privilèges n'avait
jamais eu en tant que diplomate
cela va m'aider permet aussi d'avoir des
échanges fructueux est vraiment riche et
varié avec des personnes d'origines
diverses
ce jour là dont halal en distribuer le
courrier pour la première fois à ma
propre résidence
j'ai vu mon fils qui jouer avec ses amis
au bas de l'immeuble
longs de comptes a lancé le mont du
monde ni même gêné je me suis approché
et je leur ai souri
et croyez moi j'ai tellement et
d'imaginer mais alors vraiment loin que
ce simple stories docteur aller exercer
une telle influence sur mon fils et par
ricochet sur ses petits frères
aujourd'hui encore lorsque je repense à
cet événement je me dis que peut-être
inconsciemment se saouler qui m'était
venue tout naturellement refléter mon
état d'esprit de l'époque
en fait part ce sourire je voulais sans
doute signifier à mon fils devant ses
amis et ce sans avoir à prononcer les
mots que je gardais la tête haute malgré
cette situation nouvelle et inattendue
ce sourire je le fais mais aussi de mon
père qui m'avait appris à toujours me
relever à toujours faire face et a
toujours me relever
quand je trébuche sur un sur l'obstacle
en fait à rester débout des ventes
toutes les circonstances et donc mon
père juste avec l'attitude qu'il a eu
avec ce simple sourire et m'a toujours
appris avec ce simple sourire a toujours
et toujours rester positif
et vous savez ce sourire du facteur j'ai
dû moi-même le réutiliser à plusieurs
autres moments de ma vie
par exemple j'avais 22 ans j'ai monté ma
première entreprise avec mon meilleur
ami alors vous savez à 22 ans quand vous
mettez une entreprise vous avez une
foule incroyable
on avait des rêves plein la tête on
devrait déjà multimillionnaire nous dans
deux ans
et quand quelques années plus tard ce
même meilleur ami mon meilleur ami m'a
fait un coup bas heureusement je
m'attendais pas du tout pour moi c'était
une trahison
ce jour là je me suis souvenu du sourire
du facteur et là à partir de là je me
suis relevé et aujourd'hui je dirige ma
propre entreprise et je suis même sur le
point de lancer une deuxième salle est
derrière derrière chaque attitude que
vous adoptez se trouve d'abord à
l'origine la perception que vous faites
d'un événement ou d'une situation
prenez l'exemple du lion ça y est c'est
mon animal préféré savez pourquoi
n'importe quel autre animal lorsqu'il se
retrouve devant un éléphant qu'est ce
qu'il voit un énorme gabarit une dîme
une immense bête terrifiante pas le lion
le lion lui ce qu'il va voir si son
prochain repas un c'est une occasion de
bien manger alors que l'éléphant lui au
contraire qui pourtant fait plus de 30
fois le poids du lion va se voir déjà
comme une proie
et à partir de là justement l'attitude
va en découler le lion va manger
l'éléphant et l'éléphant pas se
retrouver directement dans l'assiette du
loup donc si vous arrivez à changer la
perception que vous avez des choses
autre attitude en découlera
automatiquement et vous obtiendrez ce
que vous voulez dans la vie notre atout
de votre attitude influent sur les
personnes qui sont autour de vous et
sans même que vous ayez besoin de parler
regardez mon grand-père influencé mon
père par son attitude mon père avec ce
sourire et avec son attitude m'a
influencé aujourd'hui moi même je fais
le maximum pour vraiment impacté de
manière positive
ma fille uniquement par les actions et
vous à votre avis que retiendront
enfant de vous quel impact et qu'elle
emprunte vous souhaitez leur laisser si
vous écoutez
et en regardant les taux l'histoire de
mon père et moi on apprend que les
enfants heureux tiennent justement de
leurs parents autant ce qu'ils entendent
mais également ceux qui l'ont vu deux et
donc
2 ils accompliront
émond la manière dont vous
montrer les difficultés la manière dont
vous allez affronter un obstacle
vous allez leur laisser cet héritage
pendant toute leur vie
que vous ayez des enfants des petits
enfants ou même je vous dire que vous
travaillez avec des enfants n'oubliez
pas une chose c'est que vous êtes des
modèles pour eux mais avant tout la
première personne que vous impacté et
que vous influencer de manière positive
ou négative par votre attitude c'est
vous même alors j'aimerais vous
une question
aujourd'hui quand vous faites pas un
obstacle
quelle attitude
et vous
nous aimerions vous laissez à présent
avec
une sagesse émanant des pêcheurs
comoriens un proverbe qui nous
semble-t-il et le lustre parfaitement
l'esprit de notre propos d'aujourd'hui
permettez moi de vous citer ce proverbe
en langue coloniale il dit c'est si vrai
goujat des voix nous allons là où il ya
des vagues
c'est là où il ya une porte
merci
[Applaudissements]